et où est ce que vous dormir général
dans la rue 38% des sdf sont des femmes
pour elle la double peine à cause de
leur condition de femme
elles sont des victimes des proies livré
à la jungle de la rue un constat et en
1972 oui mais l'attaqué j'ai il vend
trop et la situation n'a pas changé en
2010 cet exemple les femmes sdf
cherchant un abri se voit proposer un
toit contre des faveurs sexuelles
pour les protéger dès les années
soixante dix des structures réservées
exclusivement aux femmes sont mises en
place
vous entendez bien avec les personnages
comme ci comme ça c'est pas toujours
m'enfin je suis très philosophe agents
qui ça va quand même
aujourd'hui encore les femmes sdf sont
considérés comme publics prioritaires
pour avoir accès aux centres
d'hébergement d'après l'insee elles sont
31% être hébergés en logement associatif
contre 19% des hommes seuls mais malgré
ça l'offre n'est pas suffisante et les
femmes doivent parfois aller dans des
centres mixtes
ce centre roquet le connaît d'autant
mieux qu'elle y vient régulièrement
pourtant elles sont toujours aussi mal à
l'aise ici il n'ya que des hommes
elle préfère rester à l'écart
les logements associatif m réintervenir
sur du long terme plutôt que de réagir à
des situations d'urgence
exemple en 1994 ce sont des personnes
qui souvent ont galéré qui journaux des
situations difficiles et donc on ne peut
raisonner la réinsertion que dans la
durée
plusieurs mois voire un an deux ans
c'est quelque chose de lourd les
demandes des femmes seules au 115 ont
augmenté de 66 % entre 2006 et 2016
selon l'armée du salut
[Musique]